where is Cara Clank in the studio guys
so happy to be considered one of your
dumb friends no it's bit well right
before you guys got a Sean already got
pissed at me even though I thought we
worked at our issues on last week's
episode Charlotte ghost was now I'm like
hey we need a story and then Shaun's
like have a better ever this John Stamos
story and I may be and then shut up I
and he angrily eats it it was the most
pathetic display of anger chandan
angrily a chips chips in a row the Jared
did an impression of Sean angrily eating
a trip to in shape guys I would have an
issue but we don't like Game two guys
who just as easily could've been angry
yet I'm not a [ __ ] right but I don't
go like I'm fired up give me that one's
on you I don't know Sean I have lost
over 40 pounds that's good family
for you buddy but raisin idea how to do
the impression is because I've angrily
eaten anything see there you go Jared on
my side but also the way will get better
so fatter than me and shook me I'm Jared
so we get to make fun of you that's how
the madness works you know immediately
if you're just a little fat or I get to
call you fat guy cos it's funny to make
fun of fat people you know even though
that you know what you're right because
I went to a camp once with all black
kids yeah and although all the light
skinned black guys wouldn't really make
fun of the dark skinned black guys yeah
it's like hard for later encore make fun
of these got and I'm thinking the same
thing yes I think that for the same
thing I think it's really good time and
all these lights can give him a call and
white child tion why are you a camp with
a black guy I wanted to recreate
dangerous minds I wanted to teach them a
lesson your mom was like we signed you
up for the cheapest oh that's how much
than when I said Jared it's also in the
jarred cadence it just sounds WAY worse
we sound you up for the other kid the
less privileged cam they don't have
archery there but they do have weapons I
wasn't it wasn't just like it was like
it was everything but like I all these
the lighter skinned black dudes would
call this one goon was a dark-skinned
black kid then called cocoa bean it
wouldn't chase him around
who's this [ __ ] things can't be calling
black people cocoa I don't know if its
water was just like your own personality
goes a split personality and you were
calling him cocoa usually the most pain
pathetic display of human emotion I've
ever seen now gotta stop stop shops go
away Dan's mad because I embarrassed in
front of in front of a girl a lot pretty
girl happens no nothing we can't nothing
we're streaming this [ __ ] what are you
talking about you came here we see me
mr. restreaming this was my mouth now
well how did you embarrassed and in
front of a girl now okay Allison bear it
was a very funny and person who I don't
know that well on the show who'd she
writes for and yes she's attractive and
I said oxymoron along I felt insecure
about that and then like what are your
ham I said what's your jam tours good
job is like that's the worst thing ever
made fun of like five with embarrass
okay not always are [ __ ] married and
this room sofas have to get out there
and you know I didn't know she's dating
some [ __ ] Hollywood star anyway the
point of oil translations very funny
we're happy we had her on a show and I
didn't enjoy it a man in my business
cannot afford to be make a look
ridiculous fredo from God fathered you
use oxymoron my son two paws instead of
redundant listed oxymoron which is like
the opposite of web that's the paradox
in warren is you use that you're really
out there kind of like trying to show
off yeah exactly you're really like
using paradox wrong it's like one of
those really all right well she was
super smothers go as one of her
throwaway phrases she was talking about
a heated argument yeah but the friend
she was it was like Lincoln Douglas like
my arms like Lincoln Douglas what is
what does that even guess it was like a
heater that was like during like a
boxing match never again later Lincoln
and Douglas like new yeah I got it yeah
Abraham Lincoln and Kirk Douglas no wow
when you say it that way but when you
say it to last me know sounds like a
boxing match hey guys it does that's
nice i'm like well that's a really smart
reference yeah so I found like a nerd
anyway i mean i just read a book about
Isis that should count for something
right I can't believe it won the [ __ ]
pol immediately worry about that what I
can wish you didn't blow your media I
wasn't looking for a board it will
respect your work you write a book about
it was
on the show because i love you the work
great show anyway I didn't realize she
was I I just it was embarrassing on two
levels it's embarrassing it's
embarrassing to like when someone who
you respect as an artist you looking to
the in front of and then and then if
they're funny that's bad and if they're
attractive on top of it it's like a
whole it's just a sandwich of anyway
well no it was fine i'm super poor with
her what i had very good rapport with
its cuz you said one [ __ ] thing tom
that's why yeah i mean unless you put
yourself out there the morning yeah one
slam dunk of aerial a Tom like brought
up like some Civil War fact he knew how
cool yes oh can we talk about the Civil
War exactly let's get these ratings item
I'm asleep every book jared is like look
at this cool book I'm reading I read
like the synopsis on the back and I'm
like I'm already asleep reading the
synopsis like Jeremy gets really boring
bucks he's like well this is a book
about uh like a boss and a young like a
ship captain and his young seaman like
whatever I feel like doing okay the like
this is a ton Billy Budd stable boy yeah
I realize I just gotta described like an
immature like homeless a homo erotic
porn but what I mean is I was really
boring [ __ ] to read I guess I love you
though no I mean let you read more i
actually liked it he's reading it seems
like he's reading historical fiction
because i remember when we me and jared
used to have a two-man show at UCB oh my
god i'm so excited about it I loved it
oh thank you but we would go downstairs
and it was a it was a historic but i
would i would dig all the historical
stuff you'd give me but then there'd be
like some of his fantasy stuff jarrett
it wasn't it was like some offer i'm not
talking dune i'm talking like some [ __ ]
no no I would read like elric of Mel
nibud II memorize the back of that book
worried about the back of the back of
the novel elric of Mel Nibin ii by
michael moorcock yeah that's something a
fake porno it's real and in the land of
sorcerous Mel Nibin II elric sits upon
the ruby throne an albino kept alive by
drugs and magic his is a path few would
choose willingly colon eternal adventure
yeah this video right now anyway those
are the kind of books I like does it
sound boring to you listeners I submit
that it is not like that or you switched
right all the time right now I'm right
now I just finished this book it's about
a guy in space and he's like a space
like fleet captain and they wake him up
from cryo sleep where he's been frozen
and they're like you have to save the
fleet you're the legendary hero in the
whole book he's just like I'm no hero
I'm just doing my job and then there's
also two women on the ship with him one
of whom is like a politician and the
other ones like a soldier and they both
kind of want to you know [ __ ] him but
he's like all that matters is my duty
Wow not actually oh it's a complete that
skirts being good and then is like nah
have any second now he's like a not
pompous hero yeah he's like I'm saying
I'm not the legendary hero you want me
to be and then he proceeds to prove that
he is over and over I should know I kind
of like that that's not getting
reluctant [ __ ] the stop slow again
deserve this no one you lost me on
albino yeah yeah Wow no that's the best
part that's a really serious look at
what a real albinos goes I feel like you
saved him though kara from completely I
know it was like I don't think you don't
do that as much right haven't said you
know why and I are married oh yeah yeah
in case any more I said you guys are
married okay in case anyone didn't um
did you save me Fred like I don't think
you go is off-brand anymore if anything
I've gotten worse no it doesn't matter I
thought you've saved them from playing
card games in the back comic book show
yeah I've had to I've had to slow down
your gaming schedule a little bit well I
said you moved to LA no have a role you
so are you solve a group you meet well
I've free like three to four to four
different groups I've upped it now that
I'm in LA
I people there's a lot of people I've
didn't like version of matt damon and
rounders take a bunch of young nerds for
all their dice from Club to club i won
all their ultra rare planeswalkers okays
game did USC wait lists all the games
they play at the dentist came out long
you're like I got the one that melt down
the back of meltdown John Malkovich is
barry sobel i did get i did have to i
had he had sex with me my father yeah he
made it in my backside oh my god yeah um
but wait back really quickly to you guys
having that show back at UCB that was
really great I actually really did like
it without you about feuds through
history and now and it was called they
hated each other and now I think Ryan
Murphy the guy who made like you know
Nick and all the American horror stories
has a show called feud yeah it's gonna
be an anthology series where he's gonna
go through famous like few days history
and carry you sent that to me and then i
sent it to dan I like dead and i
facetiously wrote they stole our show
wasn't the only thing they do that Dan
just went what are you gonna do
I'm shocked like you were just seriously
like I'm sure no I mean of course I
think they stole it but I can't steal
the idea of like doing is showing
rivalries that's how you know like
somebody's crazy though or hasn't been
doing comedy while when they're like oh
my god the guy's unit regret an airplane
I do a joke about yeah he must have
stole it sex stuff is my thing I thought
about that yeah yeah you lunatic yeah
crazy rounders thing it's fine be so
funny maybe really that'd be a funny
sketch around her steam yeah because it
was such a hit oh by the way we're also
recording and it was my podcast right
now that'd be a funny sketch on that
show yes it's from the network we're
almost trying um yeah that would be
funny I have a new podcast called
angrily eating things oh yeah more like
a vlog you need to see ya do that well
we're live in the visual haha
electronics please oh yeah there's a lot
of great product placement there's some
tiny cameras Carol what's the most
embarrassing thing you've ever done that
stage oh my god we're here afterwards
you're like I can't believe I tried to
do that you're pretty much control the
other on think it's like I don't take
you as huge risks may be as no no that's
not true well no because I'm trying to
think like what have I ever done on
state what happen if you think about it
what I just want to say this Kira excuse
me Cara's so controlled that like no one
ever heckles her like she and I go on
the road together and we'll go up in
front of a crowd rom like Jesus Christ
it's [ __ ] fury road out there yeah
kara we'll just go beat one beat to beat
three and just crush and they don't say
a word and then I get on stage and
they're like gay
sometimes I feel like they're being a
little bit like more polite because
you're a woman maybe but I think it's
your Bob personage their voice I think
you're letting your voice you having a
no-nonsense voice come to my door I got
a babysitting you ever really like you
look at New York accent but you grew up
in Connecticut well you have like a
likes you I think yeah you like a
Brooklyn now you do you added that thing
I've ever heard you do it you think I do
what are you talking about Shawn just go
no that's what I think it might be I
think like you're like you have I could
tell you i come off as like a tough
chick all right yeah so oh I don't get I
go into the crowded but I don't think
that's why that's why I don't get a heck
a lot either where people just shouting
[ __ ] out really I feel like because I go
into the crowd I gay president okay kids
don't like an operatives them like oh he
wants to talk to it he were like oh no I
teaches them yeah it teaches them this
is a conversation but you're not you
don't ever get you shocked or anything
like that uh I mean that times only when
I suck when they're talking it's like
one thing but it's like like they're
talking louder because you're talking to
them we're talking something next and
that's one thing but I never gotten like
a you just saw you shop like yelling
from the back of the thing i have one
guy in Tampa recently yelled out on top
of us the papaya healed up you shoulder
Orlando he just yells out in [ __ ]
Tampa and I go Orlando he said I mini
yell out a mildly better side in the one
man I just was just resting oh really I
just destroyed him for like seven
minutes and then Wiggins on your [ __ ]
idiot I just made fun of him and
everybody liked it and he got so bad I
went after him he left and he went
outside he was so drunk he drove all the
way they were land yeah exactly total
people from the club he thought I was
gonna be he said I thought he thought I
was gonna be a good ol boy who did
impressions and so
I got a 71 he was a good old boys you do
impressions in the songs he's not doing
a head and then he just took off I told
him what I wanted I yelled into
impression do you know Lando Johnson
question misty was at Disney we're over
the country Bear Jamboree well he wanted
like Larry the Cable Guy yeah yeah yeah
but but it was pretty funny I genuinely
just thought when you said that I'll be
kind of fun to watch right now a good
old boy that does another country Jim
punch there are three animatronic bears
like the creepily like like some a
change I mean it's freaky yeah what was
magical when you were seven is now
depressing well the worst one of those
is the universal monster rock show or
it's like every time I get ruffled I do
the wolfman shuffle you know it's like
haha but it's actual live people yeah
it's like it's fragance time playing
guitar it's at the Beetlejuice one it's
called us that yeah yeah they don't us
rocking oh there's whales like the
monsters and then I think if they're
probably the same thing would rather
watch that or go on The Motley Crue
cruise the ma blog no I'd rather watch
that because the Motley Crue's would be
a whole weekend the molly cruz i'll get
[ __ ] up anymore so it's like that's a
lot of times I could even like have fun
like hooky like getting wasted and
hooking up with like a 46 year old
divorcee the only reason to go on host
tonight yeah yeah a lot of divorce a
poon there's a lot of acid wash jeans
cruise so Jimmy these streams are on
yeah why would you say you [ __ ] up
nothing I just it feels uncomfortable
for me I don't know why cuz you're
afraid you're gonna say something stupid
dad yeah it just feels like you're not
intimate I feel like that that's that's
I don't know whose watch is this icon
periscope no it's cool no he's whining
it's a big
100 how many more logic 150 last last
last time Jimmy one person's watching oh
it's intimate again 50 people do they
all drop off no no that was the last
episode he said he's a 150 people will
watch on Wednesday weekend on a sunday
at two o'clock oh no some Perico how
many wrong guy with like a belt around
people were watching how many of you
were watching last episode on the old
things field seven so we want some time
we do know the one guy watching don't
kill your done to it Tom stopwatch every
day is a new day on periscope they said
that people are watching and then weeks
me and him started arguing and they
started dropping off like what's going
on is this a meaning they thought it was
a PPP a meeting oh my god wait Shawn you
know you were just talking about my
accent or whatever like I'm from
Connecticut do you know that I'm from
five minutes down the road from Dan that
our parents like we live practically
walking distance I mean it would be a
long walk but like our house we live
five minutes drive by jerry and i always
say honey i sound the way I sound in the
dances hey let it get either i think i
do but i don't know you don't tell you
kara has a little bit of the Connecticut
lockjaw but Jared Jared said that my at
the roast I threw for myself yes I know
Jared said Dan sounds like he's from the
Old West but he's from Westchester
I think I said you try to sound yeah
yeah oh but it's so funny we could have
run into each other it's got every bears
market on any day of the week that one
day I why cuz pound ridge is right there
right there my my parents houses three
houses from the pound ridge pork do you
like tell me what you from Jersey could
you live in jersey pretend minute I love
it up enough 10 minutes of their took me
five years oh you did 30 years old oh
and then you had to move to Westchester
to go to high school you were like a new
kid yeah move rough I want you to
develop this wild-west exam desperado
I'm the Dark Stranger Thursday all right
rooster on table is man outlaws you
became one of jared's novels the library
to Western the restaurants around I just
read the chart our I didn't really get
into it oh well dark towers blah I
didn't really get into I was thinking
about we're from the 60s hahaha The Dark
Tower while reading them we're making it
into a gunslinger Thank guns they get
into it it's [ __ ] cool you're wrong
I'm the best volume and it's the first
volume but it's been Lord of the Rings
their doctor was super thick nothing in
the two towers towers dark towers by
Stephen King and it's like his fantasy
novel it's like a weird western oh
really it's like you it's eight all
together see I can't commit to the hatch
and each one goes down in quality i
think i have this thicker when I see
people reading a book that's like six
inches thick is that like all eight put
together no no that that could be just
one of our very family in the air in the
series apparently Stephen King just
throws himself in as a character yeah so
it does this mushroom yeah yeah it does
this like multiverse thing where
sometimes they're in the real world and
stuff from the real world affects the
book yeah like people from other books
come into the dark tower series like
people from Salem's Lot and stuff people
from you
anywise yeah I 20 wife is in it right
it's cool it's like Stephen King like if
you like all of Stephen King's books The
Dark Tower like links them all together
that's what's kind of cool about it
isn't baleni wise in it throughout the
whole Randall Flagg is in the whole
thing Randall Flagg is in some of it I
think I think they make reference to
trash client in West you to stand the
black the guy in the black hat or
whatever or the black coat the man in
black man a black saree is he the same
thing as Randall Flagg or no I mean I
don't know if it's super clear and I
don't want to speak out of turn because
there are Stephen King fans who would
correct me but I believe it that's what
you're led to thank you yes that's why I
thought so yeah so it's kind of cool
it's kind of cool if you're nerdy into
that stuff but yeah i just saved wasn't
for me okay I like Stephen King know a
lot I like horror what's your favorite
Stephen King um what if I pics it I was
just thinking of the lamest on
Tommyknockers langoliers gotta be the
llangollen are they Salem's Lot Salem's
but the best one I think sale odds of my
favorite and i really like Carrie I
really koja Cujo Kodjoe I really Kojak
shank redemption it was actually good
doctor sleep was really good I didn't
read that like The Shining some demons
that's my favorite Oh Stephen kids not
even King okay what's your favorite no
it's not even King I gotta do bad all by
myself yeah that's Tyler Perry sorry
yeah I've never read a Stephen King book
I don't like was never into harm
favorite Stephen King has to be the firm
for the clients hey real big partier in
high school to like me yeah you used to
have like [ __ ] one of those like New
Canaan your house my party house I had
like three huge parties when my parents
were out of town over the course of high
school and right out of college and I
just never thought you William to the
last one oh I like didn't care about
cleaning up I cared about everybody in
school like talking about him being like
Cara the best party like I did sophomore
year and I like i coasted on like that
[ __ ] that like the chatter on that and
like an entire year
school but yeah the cops came like well
the only problem would everyone asked if
another if another town came like if the
Wilton or the darienne kids came then it
was like too many kids and it would be
Emma click on the fierce New Canaan ER
en rivalry oh god it's like the
stupidest there's a huge rivalry it's
Rams versus the Blue Wave is that is
Darian's a blue weary and father you
sick the foxes on him no [ __ ]
abstract busy ox lean hogs late is that
public right yeah and and what would you
go ride with God no no I would seek in
high school foxes the Fox Lane Fox is
excellent rock there's the fox lane
unlike the wrestling team from that box
foxcatcher Clark my um one of the people
i work with lindsey crystal who's
[ __ ] Billy Crystal's daughter but uh
well I got babies [ __ ] Billy
credentials now she is her husband her
she's awesome she's and she's a really
funny great director field producer I
don't even know the technical term is
all right go ahead anyway uh what are
you my [ __ ] Molly my gosh she's a
giant in the industry [ __ ] with you
she's taught me a lot about the business
anyway uh she's a trooper she's sure
Bruce yeah bro she's a [ __ ] national
treasure song with it with your ladies
new wave hair that you have my
joy it ok this is the [ __ ] power in
simple minds hair yes okay wait so got a
wonderful hair all right the ball buster
anyway uh anyways your husband used to
wrestle at Foxcatcher what the got the
whole [ __ ] story now we built up to
that my husband used to wrestle with him
at Foxcatcher and I've been trying to
get um on the foxcatcher team asking her
to wrestle her husband why is I want to
say I can wrestle like a foxcatcher
athlete dude I really think you like
things to read but even if he beat me
that I could say I wrestle him say you
wrestled dude I have not talked to you
about the movie foxcatcher it's the best
it's the greatest movie yes having seen
the documentary on netflix i saw that i
don't you saw that i know there's like a
really good 30 for 30 yeah yeah they're
great yeah I a movie's awesome stuff I
have them buddies what would happen if
Tim built Dylan became a billionaire
you'll become that guy by the way can
call me golden eagle and then like
casually snip okay like in there like
sponsor ho lacrosse team on his property
I just wanted to ask you guys one thing
do you think you're better than me for
the gun and shot all of you dead you
treat Harris boilers way from the movie
or is that just like weird and wrong no
it's the seventh book in the dark tower
series you also can't be like no
spoilers on a movie they came out like
four years you know I auditioned for the
guy that flies Channing Tatum to the
estate in the helotry yeah do you did
not I did I think I think you would've
made it a comedy I just can't imagine
you as a proficient toilet what are you
thinking my help
I'm gonna be frank with you I think he
might be gay he's not cool with the
subtleties guys I think he may be a
schizophrenic he has a gun and he does
not like to feel small charge but have
you read Darktown makes it online I just
love you keep you're just giving I have
a feeling he's going to shoot one of the
wrestling coaches on the property anyway
here we are some folks say I'm trying to
make my Park bigger than it is you're
fired well replacing it with Jordan
Carla subtlety rim um he would have been
great grace Helbig we're replacing youth
gray so that wouldn't have made sense
that would not have me swimming have you
ever tried out or something we probably
have tried for the same stuff and gotten
insulted by the breakdown that you have
to go in for ah absolutely yeah I do it
all the time fat uh I'm gone for fat
Rick the name of the character was
Patrick yeah I went in for that one too
yeah the famous one was got it I don't
know I think Ron Funches hey whatever a
bag of [ __ ] number two that was when I
started a breakdown said jack black
tight and that's all that's when I go
nowhere recently it said Josh GAD type
and it was time to move on my am one
that goes uh the one was a CSI cyber and
they were like in the description of the
in the side that said he there he was at
like electronic store and he goes he
waddled down the aisle did they mainly
waddle and the uh no no you just stand
right I don't [ __ ] waddle yeah take
your shirt off let me get a sailor
waddle it's not far off whatever you're
doing it may not be waddling do you take
your shirt off and waddle for us [ __ ]
you dan you're not in good shape
shame nobody said that I'm not even
close to water what are you talking
about um I wonder monologue of like an
eating disorder support group is like
what happened like what girls marry her
why do you think that's what this that's
what this is it's an eating ordered a
eating disorders he gives me [ __ ] he's
had with eating as I am I go for I go
for voice-over auditions and stuff too
and I've gotten one time I got female
Alec Baldwin hey where's less feminine
Ellen Baldwin what sectors at one time
you got a heckle that's what someone
yelled out what I mean I was like you
little pig daughter you're a [ __ ] pig
um I one time went to an audition and
the breakdown of my character said does
not suffer fools easily and it was for a
1 DS commercial we do not suffer fools
here at the Wendy excuse me i ordered a
triple not a double I'm ordering all the
99-cent menu when i ordered a baked
potato i expect chives i do not suffer
fools one of the parts i actually did
was for like that alpha dog show and i
played a crew member who tried to like
expose this politicians in this scandal
that he didn't he didn't actually save
somebody on a set of something whatever
it was but after i'm on a TV on The
Today Show and I'm giving my speech like
hey it's my book whatever you gotta
watch read my book and then after it's
like cuts to like one of the meat like
that guy mark consuelos and it's a
girlfriend in the show mr. Kelly Ripa
and then she's like why in the
girlfriend is like why would that men do
that why would he say that and he goes I
don't know I don't think he graduated
high school
that day was Andrew McCarthy was the
director of the show oh yeah forgot from
putting paying nice guy super nice guy
yeah it was just on that a show that's
women though it's a family you and me
have said that about somebody yeah but
we've been like nice guy sweaty man
humming hate swimming hey so you don't
want that to be your face ya know you
know you don't want that any human and
it is out there it is oh yeah yeah
there's a gnome you're like oh yeah yeah
you're this year like oh this is why
some of those blogs are right well not a
lot of them yeah um yeah I think I did I
talked about this friday well I did that
Super Bowl Howard Stern commercial right
yeah with a virus but I remember I did
it and I got out and I degree and I
booked it and I really needed the money
and then I went like me and Henry
Zebrowski were like talking about
auditioning and then he goes like you
wouldn't believe they wanted me to just
come into this audition be fat and dance
and then get shot off the stage of the
fire and you're like yeah I'm like that
i just put cash oh he turned it down he
turned in the audition and I just booked
it was like thank you for turning that
down I really oh well thanks Henry
yeah I did I did wear those talking head
shows reason I wouldn't say which one it
is but that you know you watch the
videos and then you come yeah videos and
they have one of them give you like 50
videos for this thing and one of the
things they want you to comment on it
was all like funny newscasts and what I
want you to comment on was it was a KFC
in some state that ran out of chicken
and it was literally oh they all the
newscasters going up these cars ask them
about hey I'd should know anything of
that and it was all black people being
like there had like freaking out about
them and I'm like and they go yeah what
do you want jokes jab are you out of
your mouth yeah it wasn't I'm gonna say
[ __ ] about this I'll agree with them
i'll say hey i love chicken too i had
Nev upset I'm either a guy who looks
like me is gonna make fun of these
people I wouldn't I would have been like
I'll do it but I'm gonna need a white
hood in a torch it was brutal uh-huh I
won't do I won't do a thing if I've
taken my shirt off like oh you continue
shirt off for this that no I'm not gonna
do I won't take my shirt yeah yeah I had
such a bad milk down on stage oh god
like two weeks ago that is where all my
clothes off on stage no didn't at the
virtual no at a smaller show at the
Virgil not like like what I'm sugar dogs
out of your boxers I got down to my
tighty whities oh god Jarrod why you
open with asking him what's the most
embarrassing day I think he's pretty
good minutes ago email our show so I've
like conscious of the fact we don't know
your [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah but I didn't
know I thought you're just happened
Bobby I explained what happened i only
have you told me I didn't even know he
told me later that I are you joking I
thought he was [ __ ] with me and then
there are photos um photo yeah they're
phonus I don't feel that bad about it
but I feel kinda bad about was a lot of
a temper ways of them you should feel
bad about what nobody angrily takes
their clothes off
angrily and take your clothes off at the
same time he should be shot in the front
let's hear what she'll was it what
happened it was I furkids show Michelle
was random don't name the shell but well
it's a random monthly at the virtual
right Meryl Davis is you don't have her
right Mara loving this he's like the
taste of failure it sustains me like oh
sweet failure like the next to a ripe
peach you are exactly right willing to
admit it I got really angry but
basically I was doing my set and it was
going pretty well but there were all
these people there who were like dressed
in costume and they were drinking
heavily and I had noticed earlier with
the earlier comics they were just just
talking full voice and they were in
costumes I think they were on some sort
of pub crawl or something but it was
like clearly like the type of person you
meet everywhere but you meet them a lot
in los angeles where they're like what
do you mean there's a show the shows
right here i brought more shot yes I'm
it's my show and I'm the center of
attention so I got on stage and at first
it was just one of that group watching
me and she was a the type of person who
has a comment for every joke so I would
finish the joke it would finish well and
then should we go say something and I
ignored it first and then I teased her a
little bit gotta laugh off of that moved
on then like this 7th or 8th times she
did it I rift on her for a little bit
and made fun of her and I got people to
laugh at her well then in incomes her
boyfriend and he's got like a stuffed
animal sticking out of his crotch and
he's dressed as Ace Ventura pet
detective I saw him I was I want to
motor when he walked up I was so angry
right away that he was just walking
around it he existed yet him so I don't
know it got really off the rails talking
to him and at some point I was like
talking about his mother just whoring
down by the dock
no I was getting laughs at first but
then the crowd started to turn on me cuz
i was being so nasty and i was clearly
like I'm trying to be funny anymore you
trying to be a [ __ ] I was just trying to
hurt him exactly by the way she even a
little bit hurt him not even a little
bit he forgot me the second he walked
out of there but I'm still thinking
about it so I attacked him and then a
bunch of them came in and they were all
drunk like that whole group of people in
costume they were yelling at me and I
was like literally like just like kind
of like [ __ ] Deering people to punch
me in the face like I stopped doing
jokes and I was just like going like
come on come on ended with me going what
do you want I'm taking my clothes I'm
going but you're just basically
everybody's inner monologue you in that
situation that that's exactly what you
want to say elder regrets they're
clearly boys right I talked to my
therapist about it two weeks I made a
couple decisions one is I don't think
I'm going to drink before I perform
anymore because when I drink and perform
that little bit of control where I go I
ignore it or wait think about it for
once again ok deal with it this way
instead that goes away my inhibitions
are gone and I just become angry and
start lashing out and the other thing is
like yeah I just need to kind of like
learn how to bomb gracefully if people
are gonna yell out and stuff sometimes
you can't fix it but it's one of those
things words like what are you supposed
to do it's one thing but you're bombing
but then when they're yelling stuff out
there anybody who comes to that thing
dressed up [ __ ] it's like you
want to be the Senate they want me to
show they did show to see her comic get
naked and start screaming so I think a
show I also thought I was I also was
just watching that I would have been
all my money's worth they were great
they shut it down I didn't shut it down
but they you know the people that ran
the show I have no problem they were
awesome and then they did arrest me
immediately after but I I really I was
this close to showing my [ __ ] oh my god
cuz i just wanted to affect people so
were you like not even in your body were
you just [ __ ] done and you had a
little bit of a break I don't know I
find were sober when that happened no
that was before may I'm about to show
you dick there must have been a moon
what you were like I'm [ __ ] it was it a
build-up from like a week of just shitty
things happening or is this just like a
moment where you were like enough with
this type of situation I'm [ __ ] done
I don't know I tell you I feel better
now and shows have not been going that
way I was a little worried you know when
I started getting back into like club
sets and stuff like cuz you know they
can be hecklers at those really drunk
people that i would start lashing out
but then i was fine 55 calm down a
little hey this weekend and he kept his
clothes on the whole time hahaha hey
hold up yeah he actually when he got
embedded here he like warren entire
gasps mat-su yeah like better safe than
sorry I'm here we're done anything crazy
drunk on stage or no well that's drug
but I'll Cara has okay yeah shows I've
ever been the only shot was ever really
drunk for was you remember um like it
was one of the little Shawny boy like
marathons at the creek yeah and like I
had like two other shows and then stango
was like you're going up at like 1145 or
something I was like okay and then I
just drank a little every show and by
the time I got on stage I was like yeah
so drunk and I think I did well like I
some people at like the next day and
they were like you were great that's
like no recollection like was I that's
like one of the only times I remember
ever being really drunk on stage and
then like I've done a bunch of those
high shows where I don't really remember
a lot of the things I oh but I got into
a fight with my Christine one time hmm I
got jokes but you would make her seem
wow sounds so out of character yeah
here's stages hi I was on stage one of
those high shows and Racine's in the
crowd and you and I were broken up at
the time yeah and he had heard me say
some story about your like say something
mean about Jared when while we were
broken up and he yelled out to me to say
it on stage like but it sounded like
we're scene was just going Jarrod like
to me while I was on stage and we were
broken up the time and it was high like
we're scene I go are you mentally retire
with this wrong with you like do you
need medication like I just like laid
into racine and like the audience was
laughing because I was like being mean
to him but it was funny and like I
remember are you feeling very funny New
York Comic brother yeah yeah in case I
assumed he'd been on the show he has but
surrender the shell friend of the shelf
and he liked but uh and then literally
think either Andy hands or nick turner
had to come up and be like okay Cara's
everything like they had they thought I
was like going gonna go crazy on we've
seen head he never said my name and you
just imagined it what I've been
imagining that you were just you just
heard my name no cuz Racine was like say
the Jared thing and I was like what are
you talking about just sent Allah he's
yelling you're a man sounded like you
yelling my ex-boyfriends name to stay on
stage while I was high doing it like I'm
already high yeah so why are ya why are
yelling missed out why are you yelling
anything I'm you show everything family
I won't have you guys been together are
you including the break man six years
six years yeah our anniversary is in a
week what you guys doing for it we're
going to Knott's Berry Farm hey
real hippie-ish I I love him he's been
works oh not spectrometer oh yeah it's
amusement park yeah well what are the
concerts were like everyone in our group
of friends besides shawn has chilled out
over the years chill down kill that damn
i have chilled out what are you [ __ ]
talking about as good as what he does
anything wrong with this kid he tries to
protect not a kid i'm 32 you know what I
mean yeah this guy I'm not in the old
neighborhood Sean look yeah Carrie you
get you get really drunk recently and
then made a little speech oh yeah my
little brother graduated from medical
school I might meet him at the party
while I was like you know why should we
talk about being a doctor right now
Caroline you never ate any foods when
you were younger and I can't escape your
doctor now like exactly cam what does it
have a [ __ ] do it it's like like
literally like a good subway Colin we
get the two now and everybody in this
video yeah already in the rooms like
what the [ __ ] she talked because I don't
know if this happens to you guys but
like people think that you're like
because you're the comedian they're like
make a little speech sandals something
you're funny at a party it was a little
party was like 40 people like it was a
massive thing but I've had to do this at
weddings where people go get up into a
little speech and I'm like I I'm really
drunk I don't think I should do that and
then people push me and then that's what
they get they get what they came for
yeah I have to urge the people like try
to get you off stage no no it was fine
my little brother maybe chance that I
house yeah and at the end i was like i
love you you're the best it was like it
ended on a good note yeah it's the most
embarrassing thing you've ever done
drugs oh my god i just always know that
Kara's drunk when she's like away from
me because she should you always answer
immediately on text unless you're bull
hammer oh yeah like well I haven't heard
from her in under a minute and that's
how she's loaded yeah about that time of
the wedding where you got mad at your
friends oh yeah the worst thing ever did
when I was drunk was I lost my friends
after a wedding and I texted the bride
and four of my other friends going this
is the meanest thing you've ever done
trip to me I texted the bride on her
wedding blood and the reason she was
gone is cuz she had broken her foot at
her own wedding oh my god getting
treated and I was writing her like
horrible text with you [ __ ] that's not
the worst thing I done but I told that
at a drunk at that blackout diary show
one time and I had photos and it was
great she was just like [ __ ] yeah
like the neck like later I found my
friends at the this is what happens when
I drink red Bull vodka cuz I'm not
allowed to drink that if I drink that I
get into like a headspace where I'm
angriest probably red bull red I've
never hit anybody like physically there
hit anyone looks up like my siblings but
Red Bull and vodka like I'll be like
what sean what what what are you trying
to say to me like I will [ __ ] Lee
have a verbal fight without you for no
reason Jack Daniels for me oh yeah like
I was out with a buddy last night and
I'm so we want to go we saw we want to
go watch the western conference finals
at big wangs but we're leaving and I'm
just not around I'll really hang out
around bars too much yeah look if I go
out on a date i'll usually go at eight
or nine and then but at that point it's
either going well enough that we weave
somewhere else or it's not gonna happen
so I'll leave anyway but we're like
outside sports bar and this one dude was
like so Tom can you hear the chewing on
the podcast do we're gonna get complace
can you just finish the pizza oh it's
just eating a pizza on one end of the
day but to do they can pick the chewing
up I'm leaning back it was worthless
kiss i'm leaning bad kids waitin doors
over oh it's overriding all right here
i'll meet you see this rub it no you
don't have to eat it it's gonna be there
in 10 [ __ ] minutes i'm gonna publish
this is the funniest podcast urban on
how bad Jimmy could you eat Tom could
you how bad you so you can hear all the
chili chips yeah the chips were did you
you camp you're [ __ ] 38 years old you
can turn the pizza in the box keeps it
hot it's not [ __ ] Jimmy's fault but
song it's gonna get less hot do you ten
[ __ ] minutes in fact [ __ ] okay wait I
really would hear what happened outside
this sports bar I mean
it's like nothin it's just like me and
my which one mellowed out over the years
yeah who's one who's still [ __ ] crazy
look at this yeah I'm trying to save you
are you guys did I married a long time
oh you know no come out I'm hanging out
with my friend David and we're outside
he's having a cigarette and we just
watched the game and these three drunk
guys came up one's wearing like a hat
and then he's like he'll have to trade
your ad for my hat and my friend hit huh
huh he goes no seriously it was like is
this gonna be a fight where this drunk I
was like trying to like I'm like he's a
shows for the idea yeah he was like no
I've been doing it all day I've been
trading hats all day that's a good way
to have lice yeah exactly and my friend
David's like I'm like I said and I'm
finally the guy backed off and I'm like
I'm like is this gonna be a thing is
this really gonna be a thing right now
and then he like backed off but it was
like one of his friends like a really
big guy could easily kicked our ass I
told you that time where I got myself
out of the situation by acting crazy
thanks for that oh those guys my friend
poured bureau will sum over some girl he
poured beer on top of her head when she
was an [ __ ] Joe and then he ran out
of the bar and then I didn't and he just
ran past me out of the bar and I just
like dude to do I just walked away and
the guys came outside and cornered me
and surrounded me I told you the story
right yeah I think so oh ok Tom Tom
we've do my job yeah but you couldn't
all right so basically we have the same
way why don't we try the story but with
you chewing pizza so see you swatch it
up a little bit same kind of thing that
you said like where you got those got
into a thing and the guy was like your
friend sucks me he left you here I go I
don't know who you're talking about your
friend that left you I go I met him
tonight man I don't know I knew this kid
for like ten years and then he goes out
your friend socks for you man he's
texting as he's texting more and more
dudes just coming over so it'll be like
15 dudes and me like on this on the
street in manhattan so i was like i have
no other course of action i was like and
i just lost my mind they go listen man I
don't know that [ __ ] guy what do you
beat me up the phone you all eager to
beat me up what the [ __ ] I didn't do
anything to you I didn't pour beer on
anybody what the [ __ ] I just freaked out
and then immediately they went
okay maybe but they were like it almost
like sobered them up or they made him
feel bad but it was good why exactly
what I'm sorry they felt sorry for you
idiot a pity yeah there was one of how
pathetic yeah right right exactly easy
albino space but don't put Senate let's
read back to those books again don't
[ __ ] listen that I go I want to [ __ ]
you want me to do and I know no song's
title okay and i wasn't letting go good
luck finding him oh can you text your
friend you look at the [ __ ] wallet
while they were going after me my friend
got a cab and he was parked right behind
him like next to that in the cab texting
me get in the cab get in the cab but
they were right there they just want to
just pounce on the cab so I was like
ignoring the text ignoring the tenth you
know you had inside of the phone yeah
that's like I although I freaked out I
just [ __ ] left it's pretty funny huh
before but it was really crazy that's
one of the craziest drunk thing I heard
that story one time but someone said you
poured the beer on somebody it was a
woman actually the woman said that she's
any pockets that's right a woman told me
you poured beer on earth that's not true
i'm a nice young well a year i don't
think it did i'm like get drunk at your
wedding and like act like an [ __ ]
yeah you did I wasn't drunk okay no I
wanna say to me was an [ __ ] like but
people like people just get really drunk
and then they just want to talk to you
for a long time and you're like the fun
weather and you're like you just leave
me alone like I got to keep it moving
but no I mean you were the biggest piece
of gossip from our wedding
have you already talked to your view we
haven't the NCAA German who [ __ ] people
for the material as you're inserting
your like this was in New York last week
for a week I just saw that girl Shekinah
on my show I go you know I go you know
st. your means using your hell you're a
little hook up on my wedding is his big
closer in LA it was like oh my god like
you doesn't like name you or anything
let me guess then you came early cuz it
would be funnier was she pissed off no
malice cuz the only thing that he did
that my wedding was come with a pack of
o'douls 12 pego dogs but yeah we hooked
up and well i mean i've talked about
others podcast right on stage I on stage
where I becuase or where I long about it
I hooked up with one of Cara's friends
in in the forest in the forest make in
that Woods makes it sound like they were
like fairy I'm flying above you not a
bed of mom you were like my wedding was
at a summer camp and it was in the woods
in one of the cabins right well I I feel
a lot of cabins yeah yeah it was well it
was started out like near a tree and
then we like move down he like tried to
do it I didn't satisfy her yeah you know
satisfaction in terms of woods sex feels
like you know the readings don't overlap
all the time yeah don't be so hard on
your thank you everyone definitely
wasn't hard that night am i right
I am the better I just feel like you
know like a gay what else get laid that
weekend yeah um well people fooled
around eh fooled around I know TV boy
who fooled around and then God I swear
to God like almost everybody at our
wedding was there with like a boyfriend
girlfriend or husband or wife yeah just
had a lot of a lot of hey it's our guest
for next week in the future just walked
in um we won't say who but uh find out
next week it rhymes with Kathy Najimy
it's Kathy Najimy um oh my god that
would be such a great guy would be a
great get for this podcast it's great on
veep oh yeah we've met her and the
snapple lady on the same podcast we're
different ENT miniseries about dr. Seuss
no I don't nerd it happened was he good
was it good damn it Jimmy what if I yeah
I remember I'm the wife of dr. Zeus I
think so I heard he hated Jews no I
always just I send every writer I heard
you invented over 23 women that's Walt
Disney right Walt Disney any juice well
there are rumors of anti-semitism and he
hired a leafy rife install da work for
EM oh well yeah the guy who with Disney
science it was like the science of
Disney or he had somebody who was a Nazi
to do a special on a woman a woman who
was the Nazi documentarian yeah we
created the film triumph of the will I
really wish I being boring no that's not
your traditional choreographed Fantasia
actually afterwards hey we gotta wrap up
and is there a dumb story we haven't
gone to guys from either Oh which was
already dumped story go don't hey uh
conversation trap oh well when you were
talking about what's the word let's tell
about it in Rome oh ok everybody sighed
and rolled their eyes
they went to Rome together wow this is
funny that together like actually four
years ago so it was like our first trip
that we ever really took and I used to
live there so I like speak a little
Italian and and I know my way around the
city so I get onto the subway and I feel
jared is not behind me first of all tell
them how I'm dressed in terms of he's
wearing a t-shirt that I got him from
the television show Portlandia that says
put a bird on it like I got it for free
somewhere and I was like hey do you want
then like a pair of short like big cargo
shorts massive cargo shorts and then
this face is the most American without
receipt in your life I had like a target
painted on yeah then you went to a store
like I do in European vacation and came
out with those wacky clothes yes but we
got on the subway and I could like feel
he wasn't right behind me so I turn
around and he's just been like swarmed
by gypsy children which is not like like
that I think some people think that's
like a racist thing to say but that's
like well it is but they are like I
don't know the word gypsy okay let's
just call it the less clean where's
little preppy outfits they wear little
like cable-knit sweaters and like khakis
but it's dirty as [ __ ] and they smell
like [ __ ] like you know so they it's
like they kind of know how they're
supposed to look but there anyway
itinerary Albanian chill yeah I do the
Albanian Runaways and they surround
Jared and they kind of boxed me out of
the subway as we were getting on it yeah
and they were obviously trying to
pickpocket him and I so I like like
Serena Malibu I get it yeah you tell so
I'm like well what are these kids trying
to do and I'll some para goes he pushes
the child down
coming into this away pushed it a child
and then care about years old 12 years
old yeah get on the train and I was like
okay and then this little kid I pushed
him onto the subway platform it's like
three of them and one of them slaps me
in the face with his jacket and I have a
jacket and I slap in the face of my
jacket old is this kid right mouth ciao
traded Karen slopped a kid in the face
with her jacket let me first and I know
these kids will take your [ __ ]
Passport through anything go in your
life literally take anything and and
then it just as the drawers are closing
I see I've dropped my jacket and I like
pull my jacket Indiana Jones my jetta
get through the door at the last second
and then the door shuts the train this
whole thing happened in like 10 seconds
so fast and we're sitting there and I'm
like we're both like it's quiet and the
whole subway and then all of a sudden
and these all families are like Brava
applauding me so that's how Kara saved
me from being violated yes did you read
you one of his girl did you forget to
bring your rapist owns that one had
fainted during martyrs which is a really
[ __ ] up movie but he painted tell me
he fainted actually fainted I became
very light here in almost fainted well
you said Emily like cried you said that
was like really really sad everybody did
Salta had a bad reaction don't see them
it means all right well you saw because
they've been doing that yeah hey this
will be out in a couple weeks anything
to promote yes oh I have a podcast
called the secret masters podcast and
kara has a park I the podcast that
that's gonna come out soon it's called
sisters but hasn't launched yet who are
you and who me and Carmen Lynch Tom fine
and she's my favorite yeah great i said
hi it's great Tom who is that I used to
remember Tom they're tossing wires I
just check out not safe with Nikki
Glaser i'll be at a hyenas comedy club
at the end of june i and i'm at i'm at
any time on twitter and i'll be at
crackers the week this comes out and
yeah that's about it oh yeah and i'll be
i'll be at lug nuts chuckle bin well
thanks for doing that that's where you
repair puppets
all right take care okay that was great
guys that was here